- If you heard the name of this show
you've heard of our first guest.
She sold over 25 million albums.
She's won, yes.
She's won The Voice four times.
She's the winner of two sports Emmys.
She does it all.
(audience clapping)
She's a mother of two beautiful children
and I'm using her dressing room today.
So let's say hi to Kelly Clarkson.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
You know,
I started to show up looking
like that today, Kelly,
but I didn't wanna do you like that
- Sometimes women don't rise Taraji,
Sometimes,
- Hey, look,
- Sometimes we fall.
- But you got up 'cause
you're on the screen.
- Look, I thought,
I thought we were done with quarantining.
And I'm so tired.
I broke a nail. I'm so broken.
This is me broken.
All my makeup's expired.
America, this is what I
look like. You're welcome.
- Well, let me say this to you, Kelly,
this is the first time I've
left my house since Christmas.
(audience clapping)
Oh, you got,
You got a couple of people
wanna say hi to you.
Y'all, y'all.
- [Kelly] Hi.
- Hi Kelly. We miss you.
- Come back, come back.
(audience clapping)
- So is there anyone
else you wanna talk to?
- Oh my God.
Hey, Roman, are you wearing
a superhero costume?
- No, I went, you know, Saved by the bell.
You weren't here.
- Saved by the bell Zack attack!
- Yeah it is, (indistinct).
- I miss y'all.
I'm not even sick. It's so weird.
Anyway, we're keeping
it safe and that's that.
- It's okay if you have wine in that mug,
we'll pretend it's coffee.
It's happy hour somewhere!